now to Montana the growing outrage over
the treatment of a transgender lawmaker
public protests in the legislature were
met with police in riot gear on Monday
this was a third straight session the
Democratic state representative Zoe
Zephyr was barred from speaking over
comments she made about a bill to ban
gender affirming care she now says she
could face censure or expulsion from the
chamber later today at the hands of the
Republican majority Meg Oliver has more
on this story
thank you
standing defiantly mundate Montana house
representative Zoe Zephyr raised her arm
holding a microphone to amplify the
voices of her supporters demanding she
no longer be silenced
The Freshman lawmaker who is transgender
tweeted last night that she faces
expulsion or censured later today that's
after Republican house leaders announced
they would vote whether her actions
violated the safety dignity or decorum
of the House of Representatives no
representative is above our house rules
for over a week Zephyr has been barred
from speaking on the house floor until
she apologized for her comments opposing
a Republican bill Banning gender
affirming care for minors if you vote
Yes on this bill
and yes on these amendments I hope the
next time there's an invocation when you
bow your heads in prayer you see the
blood on your hands Montana's Republican
house Speaker deemed those comments out
of line and that they broke house
decorum we're elected to have the hard
conversations speaking to John Dickerson
last night on CBS News streaming Zephyr
says she's not apologizing for what she
said and in fact she would say it again
when marginalized communities
communities who are impacted the most by
legislation rise up and speak to the
firm those folks in power particularly
on the far right do not want to be held
accountable
real harm that these bills bring for CBS
mornings I'm Meg Oliver